Donald Trump is so far out ahead that
the rest of the field can't even see him
this is Secretariat against the rest of
the field in the 1973 Belmont sakes Ben
Shapiro did a little selfie video last
night that I kind of thought summed up
the reality of the situation quite well
here is the very quick story Donald
Trump wins walking away all of the
pollsters called this thing pretty much
as soon as the polls open that raises
questions in and of itself about
procedure about whether that affects the
final vote tally but bottom line is they
were doing that based on the entrance
polling data Donald Trump is way out
ahead Donald Trump is so far out ahead
that the rest of the field can't even
see him this is Secretariat against the
rest of the field in the 1973 Belmont
Stakes what does that mean going forward
it means that de facto Trump is the
nominee if no one could challenge him in
Iowa if nobody really has a chance of
challenging him based on the momentum
going into New Hampshire if nobody has a
challenge for him in South Carolina then
all you can say at this point is that he
is preparing for the general election
against Joe Biden and we're already
there maybe it was always going to be
this way after all he's been treated by
the Republican electorate as the
incumbent president and he's been
treated that way because that's how they
think of him many Republicans think by
the way that he won the last election
against Joe Biden rightly or wrongly and
so why wouldn't they treat him that way
there might have been a brief moment in
time where there were Minds that were
open to be changed enough to possibly
challenge Trump but that time passed a
while ago and it's pretty obvious at
this point that Donald Trump is going to
be your Republican nominee in 2024 all
right that's Ben Shapiro being Ben
Shapiro a lot of sense uh the line that
I want to focus on maybe it was always
going to be this way that might be right
right and I never denied that here but I
think fighting the good fight and doing
it honestly and uh and forthrightly is
always worth it right like clearly I
thought and I still believe that Ronda
santis because of age because of policy
because of the picking the correct
fights and all of those things uh was
the guy for this moment but I'm not the
king of the world right so the the
caucus goers of Iowa disagreed with that
that's just fine now I can either just
fight and swim upstream and demand the
world uh acquest to me uh or I can see
the world as it is as we talked about
yesterday and I think Ben is completely
right like we know Dan santis isn't
going to do particularly well in New
Hampshire that sort of looks like it'll
be Haley's last stop and then and then
there's South Carolina but but Trump
trump has
this